cortège est parti peu après 14h du métro
école militaire direction la rue du bac
dans le 7e arrondissement
parmi les manifestants aussi bien les
organisations syndicales que des
étudiants ou encore des gilet jaune et
malgré l annonce du gouvernement de
retirer l'âge pivot tous restent
déterminés et ne réclame qu'une seule
chose le retrait pur et simple de la
réforme des retraites je propose de les
écouter la réforme est venu au bon point
pour remobiliser les gens au final parce
que les gens se rendent compte comment
ça se passe vraiment dans les
manifestations et le peu de réponses que
nous apporte quand on manifeste pour
quelque chose sur laquelle on n'est pas
d'accord et chaque sortie des manuels
maquereau ou son premier ministre
elles sont très bien aussi pour
mobiliser les gens aient un tout parce
que du coup même les grévistes qui
avaient pas encore à participer aux
rigides et jaunes et qui avait
l'habitude de manifester avant se rendre
compte de tout ce qui est en train de
passer ya là il ya beaucoup de réformes
il ya il ya la sécurité sociale qui va
arriver il ya la paix elle ya le chômage
là on est celle sur celle des retraites
mais en a plein d'autres qui arrivent en
fait c'est une course contre la montre
le gouvernement veut passer le maximum
de réformes et a pu avoir besoin de
revenir là dessus
donc c'est très dangereux à la fin de
son quinquennat et leur as limiterait le
travail leur a même eu besoin de se
représenter à la motivation elle est
entière ça c'est sûr bas toute façon
quand on voit la régression nos acquis
sociaux a peut être que entière puis on
va pas se faire voler la vedette du fait
que tout le monde est sorti aujourd'hui
c'est bien parce que on a été des
crieurs d' alerte
il est temps que les gens prennent
conscience que ce qu'on défend était
juste et qu'on n'est pas si mauvais que
ça malgré tout ce qu'a pu dire le
gouvernement dans sa communication pour
essayer de nous discréditer très peu de
tension à noter lors de cette
manifestation qui a duré un peu moins de
trois heures
les manifestants se sont retrouvés rue
du bac où ils se sont donné rendez-vous
pour jeudi pour la grande journée de
mobilisation nationale